[Music]
[Applause]
Tom Curran sent a tweet out and uh I
chuckled the worst loss of Bill bich
che's coaching career has been followed
by the second worst loss of his coaching
career which may actually be worse than
the worst loss because it was
immediately after the worst loss let's
go to Tom Curran the Patriots Insider
NBC Sports Boston hey how's your day Tom
you follow you follow on that whole
thing yeah oh man day's good nobody
wants to engage
in what amounts to a coing coaching
death watch for a legend and you know
you wake up today honestly Dan you wake
up over your career in sports say holy
crap I can't believe that happened
overnight and I'm waking up this morning
saying please don't don't don't let me
see Bill bich relieved of his duties
it's that bad man well they wouldn't let
him go during the season
Robert CRA would never do that yeah I
think that the chances of that are
infantes small but covering this team as
long as I have and the number of Bizarro
stories and things that I've woken up to
or learned in the middle of the day
while driving a kid to Little League
practice or found out on my own it's
there's nothing that's beyond the realm
and and what we've seen over the last
two weeks and really the last five years
going back to the midpoint of 2019 four
years um is jarring enough to say
everything's on the
table are they
hopeless yeah they are well and I and
I'm a guy who said they could win 10
games I went into the season thinking
this could be a 10- win team just on the
logic that well they were a 10- win team
in 2021 you brought Bill O'Brien back
he's going to wave the magic wand he's
going to be the enema for the entire
offense they're going to return to being
what they were in large part and the
defense is better so even if it's a more
difficult schedule they can get there
and I swear to God Dan I believed it
after the first two weeks because I said
they just all they have to do is stop
throwing picks and having penalties they
outplayed Philadelphia they were right
there with Miami all they got to do is
go into Dallas and win 31 to 23 I said
31 to 23 I
said if anybody else was coaching that
team would you have had the same kind of
let's say Bill O'Brien was coaching not
bill bellich
would you have the same kind of optimis
it feels like your optimism is just
based on trusting bellich yeah it is it
it is completely
because we've seen a team that was
situationally smart incredibly well
disciplined well coached and always the
whole was greater than the sum of its
parts for two decades and they didn't
beat themselves they were a league
leader in fewest
penalties they would have no clock
management issues few times that they
would have any kind kind of
situational meltdowns yet what we've
seen since really the midpoint of last
year is you know the Las Vegas thing
which was beyond the realm of all
possibility throwing it backwards behind
your head the next guy who catches it
actually throws it even further
backwards to the quarterback who gets
stiff armed into Hades and they follow
that up by falling behind in the very
next week 22 to nothing against
Cincinnati at home by halftime on
Christmas Eve and then they finish the
season allowing two kickoff return
touchdowns to Buffalo so I said just
stop being stupid and you'll win games
and I believe that through the first two
weeks just stop being stupid play like a
bill bichi team but I think it's now
into their DNA and I think that last
year they were so poorly coached that
they remain poorly coached bill is still
there
but the players don't execute in a way
that you'd say that was a smart play
yeah and you don't think of Patriot
players quitting and it feels like that
watching yesterday that maybe maximum
effort didn't last long if you knew
belich was going to answer a question
honestly what would be the question you
would ask
today how
much of
this is based on the roster decisions
you've made for the last five years
whether it's you know whether and the
Brady thing honestly we can all look at
that as a a watershed moment it had gone
completely Beyond The Pale the
dysfunction was there that he had done
such a poor job building the team around
Brady at that point that you're
basically just keeping him as a
figurehead and I get why he had to move
on but whether it be no succession plan
for Tom no succession plan for McDaniels
signings of Nelson agalar and jonu Smith
I mean how much blame do you accept for
being unable to evaluate talent and look
at the players who are sitting right in
front of you
and say yeah he's not good I like Juju
Smith Shuster I don't like Jobe Meyers
like how did that happen how did he get
so bad at being able to tell a good
player talking to Tom cerran he covers
the Patriots for NBC Sports Boston is M
Jones going to be the starter next
year next
year boy Dan these ones don't get any
easier
um yeah he'll be the starter next year
just because he's cost effective he's on
the final year of his rookie contract
and in for a dime in for a dollar
they're probably not going to get high
enough to take a rookie quarterback and
if they do get high enough to take a
rookie quarterback do him the solid of
letting him learn behind Mack even
though Mack's probably gonna putout
around the place the whole summer um
just do him that solid because you want
to ring and that's what's again
egregious if you're Robert Craft you're
sitting there
look he's on a rookie contract what are
we doing so it look at the amount of
wait that's your Robert Craft
impersonation yes it is I I don't know
what the hell's going on you look at the
situation and we had the greatest
quarterback of all time and we just let
him go um got to touch of Seinfeld in
there I mean terally I'll just a it yeah
um well you got the fifth pick in the
draft right
now anything can happen Dan honestly if
you were bill bellich would you wake up
this morning and say think it's time for
me to wrap it up or would you say I am
chasing schula would you look at that
Don schula poster on your wall and just
say I'm Coming For You
jaw um Let me let me ask you this I I'm
gonna no I asked you okay so what's the
question the question is if you were
bill bellich would your heart still be
in it this morning to chase Don
Shula it it would be out of spite but
you know at some point you know you you
you can't write hit songs anymore you
know you see this with an artist they
can't write a song you know like hey you
haven't had a hit in you know five years
um but at some point I have to look at
that person and say does Bill can Bill
write another hit song can he have
another playoff toam um he's got his two
best defenders who were out he does
really very little on off defense he has
a quarterback that probably is not a
starting quarterback so that would be it
would be hard to you know drag the ball
and chain into work every single day
yeah it would be yeah he's Tom Jones at
this point well Billy Joel hadn't
written a you know a hit in a long time
30 years so but let me ask you this if I
put Brock pie on the Patriots and Ma
Jones on the 49ers
you'd be looking at two teams with very
similar results to what you're looking
at right now it's a
total I don't know if prie would be
pouring gasoline on the fire in the same
fashion that Mac is but record-wise it
would be the same and Ma Jones is so
wholly capable of operating when things
are good around him that he'd be
absolutely fine you got a stationary
quarterback
with an average arm whose greatest
strength is
accuracy and
anticipation and he needs time to
execute those things yet he doesn't know
what he's going to be looking at 1.1
seconds after the snap so you've made
him you you know compounded the error by
the players you've put around him
whether it be it offensive line which
has just really been a disgrace or um at
the receiver positions we haven't been
able to pick players who are impact
players this is the first time I think
in the history of our show we've talked
to hopeless Tom hopeless Tom hopeless
Tom hopeless Tom coming at you it's some
Monday yeah you had a good run though I
mean you had a good you know yeah I
probably won't be talking to you for a
while huh round the draft bellich check
nobody needs yeah nobody needs down
nobody needs this on a Monday
morning it's all hop yeah but not going
to get any better why do you want to get
out of bed in the morning
Bill are what are you going to ask him
what question are you going to ask him
uh
Wednesday
uh you know probably some pum I mean
what am I gonna get two snorts a shrug
and
a it's diminishing returns at this point
that should be the name of your book on
bellich two SN yes the bellich
story yeah all right sorry about this so
I mean it's tough I mean you're down
there in in nutmeg Connecticut or
whatever it is yeah you're you're inside
the I mean if you're Robert Craft and
you're looking at the place just clear
out yeah on a Sunday after a 38 to3 loss
the week before and then you come home
and lose 34 to nothing in front of fans
who are well aware that Robert said this
is no more Al the not winning games
and you have to watch you just did Marin
Rando
there you got to work on that you got to
work on really yeah you got to work on
that if you're GNA take it nationally
yeah you got to work on that I just did
take it nationally didn't I it's a
national program isn't it yeah but you
know like a well listen to National show
you know oh no we are you're like Tom
Jones too yeah yeah Tom
Brady all right um hey great to talk to
you keep keep your morale up see you at
the retirement party alrighty thank you
Tom bye Tom Cur